وحده على المحك
عزيزه الحرب على اوكرانيا تماسك الاتحاد
الاوروبي في موقفه الداعم ليكيف لكن
التحديات التي انشاتها الحرب سرعان ما
شوشت على حاله الاجماع تلك
المساعدات الماليه العسكريه لاوكرانيا
وفرض حزم العقوبات على روسيا لم يكن اي
منها ليخفي التباين في مقاربه شركاء
الاوروبيين للاسماء
الطاقه هي ما اطلقت التحدي الاكبر
يتحولت اوروبا الى المتضرر الابرازي من
الحرب وما تلاها من اجراءات روسيه خلصت
امدادات الغاز الى القاره العجوز
اضحى حيويا هنا تامين بديل لامدادات الغاز
الروسي دون ان يضارب شركاء بعضهم على بعض
في الاسواق العالميه
في ايجاد اتفاقا يسمح بالمضيق قدما فيما
يخص القرارات المختلفه لحمايه المستهلكين
والمؤسسات الاوروبيه هذا الاتفاق سيحققوا
ثلاثه اهداف هي تامين امدادات الغاز
الخاصه بنا وحمايه المؤسسات الاقتصاديه
والافراد في القاره واستقرار الاسواق
الماليه وهي مساله مطروحه للنقاش حيث نريد
استقرار هذه الاسواق
لكن الاوروبيين بداوا حتى الان عاجزين على
التوافق على صيغه لتسعير الغاز لمواجهه
الازمه التي تشتد قسوه مع حلول الشتاء
ليس هناك عجزهم الاول ولا منتهى خلافاتهم
نذكر مثلا ال مقترح المفوضيه الاوروبيه
فرض حظر تدريجي على النفط ومشتقات نفط
الروسيه ردا على الحرب في اوكرانيا
بمنطق مصالحها لم تتح مساحه للاجماع ودون
اجماع قد تنفرد دول اعضاء بخطط وقرارات
كتيلك التي حفزت ازمه صامته بين بعضها
وتلك اجتهادات غايتها تامين مصادر الطاقه
واسعارها وسياسه نمو الاقتصادي بشكل عام
لكن كثيرين يرون فيها اختبارا اخر لتماسك
الاتحاد وتحديا لديه حاله التضامن التي
اوجدتها الحرب في اوكرانيا